avant que la vidéo ne commence j'ai une
question à vous poser vous croyez
vraiment que les gens ont lu tous les
livres dont ils parlent bien sûr que non
sinon on ne pourrait pas parler de grand
chose
ah oui il y a 24 heures dans une journée
et il faut travailler manger dormir et
sortir le chien
[Musique]
donc le secret de la culture générale ce
n'est pas de lire des livres c'est quoi
alors en fait il n'y a pas un seul
secret il y en a 5 les étudiants et les
personnes les plus cultivées les profs
et les intellectuels connaissent ces
cinq secrets savez vous avez lu Ronan
comme moi mais il se garde bien d'en
parler les gens qui les découvrent
réussissent à développer rapidement et
facilement leur culture générale parce
que leur rapport au savoir a changé et
une fois qu'ils appliquent les 5 secrets
ils comprennent toutes les références
des personnes cultivées ils savent
s'exprimer avec profondeur sur n'importe
quel sujet il brille par leur culture
dans les conversations et dans les
débats et ils ont le recul nécessaire
pour faire preuve d'esprit critique ça
vous intéresse et bien je vous révèle
les cinq secrets et je vous explique
comment les appliquer dès aujourd'hui
pour vous cultiver dix fois plus
rapidement sans vous prendre la tête
pour recevoir les cinq secrets
inscrivez-vous simplement soit en
cliquant sur le lien qui apparaît
maintenant en haut à droite de la vidéo
soit sur celui qui est dans la
description de la vidéo c'est l'histoire
de 10 secondes donc faites le maintenant
et vous pourrez découvrir le premier
secret qui vous attendra bien au chaud
dans votre boîte mail après avoir
regardé cette vidéo voilà voilà je vous
ai dit ce que je voulais vous dire bonne
vidéo
[Musique]
première référence les romans de la
Table Ronde de chrétiens de Troie
les cinéastes américains et amis Georges
Lucas et Stephen Spielberg se sont
inspirés de Lancelot un personnage des
romans de la Table Ronde de chrétiens de
Troie pour créer le personnage d'Indiana
Jones dans les années 1980 tout comme le
chevalier de la littérature française du
12e siècle l'archéologue américain se
lance dans diverses aventures pour
récupérer des artefacts anciens et ces
péripéties se déroulent dans une
atmosphère mythologique qui rappelle
celle des récits de chrétiens de Troyes
cette atmosphère mythologique est plus
précisément celle des légendes
arthuriennes on qualifie ces légendes
d'arthurienne parce qu'elles sont
centrées sur la légende du roi Arthur un
seigneur breton qui aurait résisté au
barbare au milieu du premier millénaire
les chevaliers de ce roi s'appelaient
les Chevaliers de la Table Ronde c'est
pourquoi leurs histoires s'appellent les
romans de la Table Ronde ils étaient
notamment en quête du Graal un objet
mythique dont la possession permettrait
de rétablir la paix dans le royaume
qu'on retrouve l'influence de ces
légendes dans les super productions
américaines de la fin du 20e siècle
révèle bien l'importance des romans de
la Table Ronde de chrétiens de Troyes
dans la culture populaire occidentale
comment dire sur le plan de la forme ces
romans ont été écrits en ancien français
la première langue française en usage du
neuvième au 13e siècle et qui dérivait
du latin parlé mais ces romans sont
aujourd'hui disponibles dans des
traductions modernes très digestes qui
préservent l'identité du style initial
chrétien de Troie écrit envers
octethosyllabique donc oui syllabes la
forme poétique typique de la littérature
médiévale française son style est
poétique c'est-à-dire qu'il produit de
belles images d'un côté la richesse des
descriptions et les références
culturelles datées rebutent des lecteurs
modernes comme nous mais de l'autre côté
nous apprécions encore la finesse
psychologique avec laquelle chrétien de
Troie présente ses personnages et puis
le ton de la narration est souvent
ironique et humoristique enfin la
structure narrative est assez complexe
notamment Chrétien de Troyes en chasse
les récits
je vous résume très rapidement ces trois
plus importants romans Yvain ou le
chevalier au lion raconte l'histoire
divin chevalier à la cour du roi Arthur
qui va d'aventure en aventure où il
prend la défense des faibles avec un
lion qui l'a sauvé afin de convaincre
son épouse de le reprendre on retrouve
donc le thème de la vertu en oblissante
de l'amour Yvain se dépasse par des
actions d'une grande noblesse pour
reséduire sa femme vous avez peut-être
étudié cette histoire si vous avez fait
votre scolarité dans un collège français
deuxième roman important de chrétiens de
Troie Lancelot ou le chevalier de la
charrette raconte l'histoire de
chevaliers de la cour du roi Arthur qui
enchaîne les aventures pour ramener la
reine Guenièvre enlevée par un
mystérieux étranger une idée importante
de ce roman c'est qu'il faut accepter
l'humiliation par amour car Lancelot
accepte de circuler sur une charrette
comme un manant c'est à dire un homme de
basse conditions plutôt que sur un
cheval c'est encore un classique des
cours de français au collège
troisième et dernier roman important de
chrétiens de Troie le Conte du Graal ou
le roman de Perceval qui était inachevé
raconte l'histoire de Perceval qui
devient Chevalier contre la volonté de
sa mère dont le mari et les autres fils
étaient déjà mort au combat ces
prouesses de chevaliers le font inviter
par un roi misérable au château il
assiste à un étrange spectacle une
procession où l'on porte un grand vase
le Graal et une lance qui saigne ce
n'est qu'après des années de
pérégrination qu'il peut assister de
nouveau à la procession et poser les
questions qui rendraient la prospérité
au pays au début du 13e siècle une
grande tradition romanesque se centrera
autour du Graal qui deviendra même un
accessoire de Jésus-Christ et des
auteurs réécriront l'histoire de
Lancelot on retrouvera encore le Graal
dans les aventures d'Indiana Jones
les romans de la Table Ronde de
chrétiens de Troie sont très importants
dans la littérature française parce
qu'il symbolise la naissance de la
formule littéraire du roman qu'est-ce
qu'un roman à l'origine c'est simplement
une traduction d'un ouvrage du latin en
langue romane d'où le nom de roman le
mot désigne donc d'abord toute
production littéraire en langue romane
mais ces productions racontent souvent
le même type d'histoire donc la
définition de ce qu'est un roman se
précise au 12e siècle un roman désigne
désormais un récit d'aventure en
français ou l'amour tient une large
place les romans de la Table Ronde de
chrétiens de Troie sont donc aussi
importants sur le fond par leur thème il
lance ce qu’on appelle la littérature
courtoise les deux ingrédients de cette
littérature ce sont la chevalerie et
l'amour dit courtois l'amour courtois
c'est l'idéal amoureux née dans les
cours d'où l'adjectif courtois dans les
cours du moyen-âge et cet idéal prescrit
que l'homme adore en souffrant une femme
inaccessible plein d'autres auteurs du
Moyen-Âge inventeront des histoires sur
le même modèle un chevalier errant
solitaire qui s'engage dans une série
d'épreuves pour prouver sa valeur
effacer une faute souvent vis-à-vis
d'une femme ou pour conjurer un
sortilège la dimension psychologique du
parcours du personnage dans ce modèle de
récit en fait le personnage est en quête
de maturité cette dimension
psychologique est à l'origine de la
tradition européenne dite du roman
d'apprentissage ou Bild dooms en
allemand les illusions perdues de Balzac
ou l'éducation sentimentale de Flaubert
seront de fameuses exemples de cette
tradition au XIXe siècle en France on
retrouvera plus globalement les thèmes
des romans de la Table Ronde dans
certains des chefs-d'œuvre de la
littérature française par exemple
Rabelais fera une satire des codes de la
chevalerie dans Gargantua en décrivant
des combats absurdes et excessifs tout
en donnant à son protagoniste la
noblesse dame qu'on attend de l'idéal
chevaleresque
deuxième référence Gargantua de François
Rabelais
en 1564 l'Église catholique inscrit
Gargantua de Rabelais à l'index librorum
prohibitorum en français index des
livres interdits le langage du roman est
jugé obscène par les autorités
religieuses sont contenu est jugé
scandaleux mais cela n'empêche pas les
éditeurs d'imprimer de nombreuses
éditions qui circulent dans toute
l'Europe ce roman inspirera des
générations d'auteurs français jusqu'au
20e siècle où les autorités l'inscrivent
à une autre liste celle des classiques
de la littérature française le nom
Gargantua est même passé dans la langue
française il a donné l'adjectif
gargantuesque qui signifie démesuré la
plupart du temps en parlant de la
quantité de nourriture on peut par
exemple dire qu'un repas a été
gargantuesque sur le plan du style
Rabelais est à la fois grossier et
inventif il crée des jeux de mots et des
expressions comiques en jouant avec la
langue française il est l'auteur de
nombreux néologisme par exemple il
invente le mot automate pour désigner de
petits engins qui se déplacent de
manière autonome autre exemple
intéressant il donne un nouveau sens au
mot quintessence qui désignait autrefois
l'essence du ciel qui est la cinquième
essence après les quatre éléments que
sont la terre l'air l'eau et le feu mais
Rabelais lui emploie le mot quintessence
pour désigner ce qu'il y a de plus
important et de meilleurs dans une chose
on peut dire tirer la quintessence d'un
livre par exemple le langage et la
structure narrative rendent Gargantua
difficile à lire pour un francophone du
21e siècle mais on peut toujours goûter
l'humour et l'inventivité de Rabelais
Gargantua et ce qu'on appelle
aujourd'hui un préquel en effet Rabelais
a d'abord écrit Pantagruel le roman qui
comme son titre l'indique raconte les
aventures de Pantagruel le fils du géant
Gargantua Pantagruel a connu un succès
immédiat ce qui a incité Rabelais à
écrire sur le père le roman débute avec
la naissance extraordinaire de Gargantua
fils d'un roi il naît de l'oreille de sa
mère en demandant immédiatement à boire
ce qui lui vaut son nom Gargantua
signifie en effet quel gosier garganté
en Languedoc tu as garganté tu as au
cours de son enfance son père persuadé
de sa grande intelligence lui attribue
un précepteur qui l’éduque de manière
archaïque plus tard le père décide de
d'envoyer Gargantua étudié à Paris où il
fait les 400 coups il vole notamment les
cloches de Notre-Dame ce qui parodie les
exploits chevaleresque finalement il
rejoint son précepteur qui constatant
ses mauvaises manières entreprendre le
remettre sur le droit chemin des
Écritures saintes Gargantua acquiert
alors de nombreux savoir intellectuels
pendant ce temps son père entre en
guerre contre un autre roi et demande
l'aide de son fils s'en suive de
nombreux combats et victoires les années
d'apprentissage et les exploits à
guerriers de Gargantua servent de
prétexte à un plaidoyer pour une
éducation humaniste fondée sur la
curiosité intellectuelle la morale
libérale de l'histoire est contenue dans
la devise de l'abbaye utopique imaginée
à la fin du roman l'abbaye de telm fait
ce que tu voudras
pourquoi ce roman est-il si important
dans la littérature française tout
d'abord il est emblématique du genre dit
picaresque l'adjectif picaresque vient
de l'espagnol picaro qui signifie coquin
le roman picarest est donc important de
la littérature espagnole et il raconte
les aventures d'un personnage de base
extraction le picaro un mauvais garçon
qui n'a pour lui que sa débrouillardise
ensuite Gargantua a également marqué la
littérature française par son plaidoyer
pour une éducation humaniste je précise
que l'humanisme est le courant culturel
de la Renaissance qui veut relever la
dignité de l'esprit humain en reliant la
culture moderne à la culture antique
dans le récit l'éducation médiévale
classique que reçoit Gargantua est
abrutissante et ne le prépare pas au
défi de la vie réelle l'éducation
alternative dessinée par Rabelais repose
sur la curiosité et non pas sur la
tradition et l'autorité intellectuelle
c'est idéal a inspirera notamment les
auteurs des Lumières
plus profondément enfin le roman
illustre le message général de Rabelais
il invite l'homme à vivre librement et
avec réalisme il faut prendre en charge
sa propre destinée plutôt que de s'en
remettre aux religions en particulier il
ne faut pas écouter les partisans de la
mythologie de l'amour passion qui
dévalorise la vie matérielle il est
légitime d'aimer le monde et de tirer
des joies du passage sur terre Rabelais
souligne aussi plus précisément un
risque de l'identité artistique de la
Renaissance il ne faut pas que l’infé
audacion aux anciens remplace
lymphéodation à l'église en faisant une
apologie de la liberté intellectuelle
sous une forme audacieuse Rabelais écrit
un roman qui sera longtemps un des plus
populaires de la littérature française
il la marque de son empreinte à la fois
sur la forme et sur le fond en
enrichissant la langue française et en
ouvrant la voie à la satire sociale et
politique on peut dire à cet égard que
Molière sera le plus célèbre héritier de
Rabelais
troisième référence la Princesse de
Clèves madame de Lafayette
début 2006 Nicolas Sarkozy alors
ministre de l'Intérieur et candidat à la
prochaine élection présidentielle promet
devant une assemblée de fonctionnaires
je cite dans finir avec la pression des
concours et des examens et illustre
cette promesse en racontant qu'il a vu
que le programme du concours d'attacher
d'administration prévoit d'interroger
les candidats sur la Princesse de Clèves
de Madame de La Fayette à ses yeux il
est parfaitement inutile qu'un
fonctionnaire soit capable de parler de
cette œuvre ça remarque fait un tôler
chez les enseignants les artistes et les
intellectuels qui voient le projet
d'enterrer la culture littéraire en
revanche les éditeurs ne sont pas
mécontents le livre redevient un
best-seller dans les trois années
suivant la déclaration du ministre de
l'Intérieur au point de parler d'un
effet Sarkozy la Princesse de Clèves a
toujours été un classique de la
littérature française mais son nom est
désormais attaché à une polémique
politique récente d'où son regain de
notoriété
maintenant quoi retenir à propos du
roman lui-même sur la forme le style de
Madame de Lafayette est emblématique du
classicisme français qui valorise la
clarté et la rigueur de l'expression le
philosophe Pascal qui est un des plus
grands représentants de ce style disait
je cite l'éloquence se passe de
l'éloquence autrement dit il faut faire
simple conformément à cette idéal de se
briété madame de Lafayette décrit les
émotions les pensées et les actions des
personnages avec un langage épuré en
évitant les ornements inutiles elle
reste à distance de l'histoire en la
racontant à la troisième personne avec
une narration omnisciente et en mettant
à profit la forme passive qui donne un
caractère impersonnel à ses descriptions
petite anecdote intéressante madame de
Lafayette ne signait pas ses œuvres de
son vivant parce qu'elle ne voulait pas
laisser croire qu'elle avait besoin de
vendre des livres pour vivre
je vous résume rapidement l'histoire qui
se passe sous le règne du roi de France
Henri II au 16e siècle madame de
Lafayette étante elle une femme de
lettres du siècle suivant l'héroïne
mademoiselle de Chartres est une jeune
femme d'une grande beauté élevée dans la
vertu après être entré à la cour du roi
Henri II et l'épouse le prince de club
et devient donc la Princesse de Clèves
cet homme d’âge mûr était pris d'elle
mais ce n'est pas réciproque elle estime
son mari sans avoir de sentiments pour
lui c'est un autre homme qui va lui
inspirer des sentiments le duc de
Nemours qu'elle rencontre lors d'un bal
là la passion est réciproque il sème
violemment le duc de Nemours veut vivre
cette passion mais la Princesse de
Clèves veut rester digne de l'engagement
qu'elle a pris auprès de son mari donc
elle se retire de la cour et en avoue la
raison à son vieux mari ce qui le fait
mourir de jalousie il ne souffre pas
seulement il meurt vraiment alors
qu'elle pourrait vivre son amour avec le
duc de Nemours la Princesse de Clèves se
retire dans un couvent jusqu'à la fin de
ses jours
ce scénario illustre un débat des salons
galants de l’époque comment une femme
mariée doit-elle réagir si un homme lui
confie son amour la Princesse de Clèves
est un des plus grands romans français
pour plusieurs raisons la première c'est
l'innovation que représente l'approche
psychologique de Madame de Lafayette
plutôt que de privilégier l'intrigue et
l'action elle entre dans la tête des
personnages pour décrire leur pensée et
leur motivation elle a donc écrit un des
premiers romans psychologiques de la
littérature française ensuite ce roman a
un intérêt historique c'est un
témoignage sur les relations humaines à
la cour du roi de France au XVIème
siècle une autre raison de l'importance
du roman c'est que madame de Lafayette
parle d'amour d'une manière à la fois
originale et subtile avec pour toile de
fond l'attention entre la passion et la
vertu la victoire finale de la vertu
illustre la nécessité de se tenir à
l'écart des plaisirs du monde c'était un
des grands thèmes du genre séisme la
nouvelle version du catholicisme qui se
développe sous Louis XIV et qui inspire
de grands auteurs comme Pascal
enfin la Princesse de Clèves deviendra
aussi une référence de la littérature
française en tant que modèle de
l'excellence sur le plan du style de la
prose classique en plus de l'approche
psychologique et historique ce roman
stimulera la littérature féminine c'est
un roman écrit par une femme pour un
public féminin et il stimulera également
la forme de la nouvelle la Princesse de
Clèves est divisée en cours chapitre et
puis la narration a le souci de la
vraisemblance qui caractérise le genre
de la nouvelle
quatrième référence les liaisons
dangereuses pierres Chauderlot de Laclos
en 1959 le réalisateur français Roger
Vadim réalise la première adaptation de
ce roman seulement le tout neuf
ministère des Affaires Culturelles
confiées par le général de Gaulle à
André Malraux et certaines autorités
locales jugent que le film violent les
normes de la décence de l'époque il est
donc en partie censuré ce livre qui
avait créé le scandale à la veille de la
Révolution française continue donc de
menacer la morale sociale près de 200
ans plus tard les liaisons dangereuses
passent pour le dernier grand roman
épistolaire la Clo réussit à donner une
impression de spontanéité et
d'authenticité aux lettres échangées
entre les personnages son style est
clair précis et concis en même temps il
réussit bien à exprimer la complexité de
la psychologie des personnages leur
lettre sont souvent remplies de
sous-entendus qui crée une atmosphère de
duplicité elles expriment grâce à la
plume de l'auteur un mélange subtil
d'ambition et de vulnérabilité Laclos
affecte même à chacun de ces personnages
un style qui permet au lecteur d'elle et
quelques premières phrases de chaque
lettre de reconnaître la patte de celui
ou celle qui l'écrit pour quelqu'un qui
n'a jamais eu à faire aux français du
XVIIIe siècle la prose de Laclos ne sera
pas forcément une partie de plaisir mais
si vous n'êtes pas dans ce cas ce roman
sera probablement une lecture agréable
je vous en résume le fond rapidement il
est composé de 175 lettres d'un duo
machiavélique d'aristocrate Valmont un
homme fortuné et oisif passent son temps
à séduire les femmes il complète avec la
marquise de Merteuil pour corrompre une
jeune fille Cécile ainsi qu'une honnête
femme madame de Tourvelle c'est intrigue
sert à critiquer le libertinage les deux
comploteurs finissent mal l'argument de
Laclos est que l'idéal libertin ne
consiste pas à prendre du plaisir avec
autrui mais à dominer et corrompre
seulement le succès du livre est dû à la
peinture qu'il fait du libertinage
c'est-à-dire fondamentalement à la
puissance d'attraction de l'interdit à
sa parution les gens le lisent
secrètement pour mieux s'offusquer de
son parfum de soufre et de ses allusions
sexuelles avec le temps les liaisons
dangereuses symboliseront dans
l'histoire de la littérature française
le développement du roman libertin à
l'époque des Lumières on peut aussi
citer l'autobiographie de Casanova et
l'oeuvre du Marquis de Sade à propos
duquel j'ai déjà fait une vidéo sur
cette chaîne l'idéologie des lumières
promeut le papillonn age sexuel parce
que la logique du désir fait qu'il ne
peut pas rester intense sans changer
d'objet le roman passera également à la
postérité comme un modèle de critique
sociale en effet la Clo donne à voir
l'hypocrisie de la haute société
française de son époque ainsi que des
relations homme-femmes enfin les lettres
dévoilant la complexité de l’âme humaine
certains voient dans Les Liaisons
dangereuses elle annonce du réalisme
psychologique dont feront preuve les
romanciers du XIXe siècle
ce roman aura une influence durable dans
la culture occidentale comme le prouve
les multiples adaptations dont il a fait
l'objet au cinéma celle réalisée en 1988
par le réalisateur anglais Stephen
freeers avec notamment John Malkovich
dans le rôle du vicomte de Valmont cette
adaptation remportera trois Oscars bien
sûr les producteurs misent sur cette
histoire pour bénéficier de la puissance
d'attraction du tabou de la sexualité
une adaptation de l'intrigue au monde
adolescent réalisée en 1999 a d'ailleurs
un titre très suggestif en français sexe
intention cruel intention en anglais
cinquième référence Le Rouge et le Noir
Stendhal
il estime que l'élégance creuse des
auteurs de son temps les condamnent à ne
plus être lu par les générations futures
je médite il un billet à la loterie dont
le gros lot se résume à ceci être lu en
1935 c'est vrai que Stendhal est
toujours lu mais il avait quand même
sous-estimé l'exigence de simplicité des
lecteurs du 21e siècle dont beaucoup se
plaignent que le rouge et le noir est
trop difficile à lire enfin le style de
Stendhal s'explique aussi par ses
conditions de production pour parler un
peu comme un marxiste ayant des
problèmes de vue Stendhal dicte souvent
ses textes à des amis ou à des
secrétaires cette manière de faire
favorise les phrases de courtes et
directes et donnent par là à la prose la
spontanéité de l'oral
passons au fond maintenant voici tout
d'abord le sens du titre Stendhal ne l'a
pas expliqué lui-même mais l'explication
la plus courante et que le rouge et la
couleur des habits de l'armée tandis que
le noir et la couleur des habits des
prêtres dans le roman le héros hésite
entre d'une part un destin militaire car
il a une passion pour Napoléon et
d'autre part l'institution religieuse
qui a favorisé son ascension sociale en
lui permettant d'étudier
je vous résume rapidement l'intrigue et
qui est inspirée d'un fait divers le
protagoniste s'appelle Julien Sorel fils
d'un sieur d'un village de Franche-Comté
il a du goût pour les idées et un
potentiel intellectuel contrairement à
son père artisan la première partie de
l'histoire se passe en Franche-Comté
Julien est un jeune homme chétif de 19
ans sa famille méprise son attrait pour
les idées mais il bénéficie du soutien
d'un abbé cela lui permet d'être engagé
par le maire du village monsieur de
Raynal a comme précepteur des enfants il
vit alors une idylle avec la femme de
son employeur à Madame de Reynal et
lorsque leur relation commence à
éveiller les soupçons le maire le
contraint à partir envisageant une
carrière dans l'église Julien entre au
séminaire de Besançon un abbé il détecte
son ambition de savoir et l'envoi à
Paris comme secrétaire du marquis de La
Mole
la seconde partie de l'histoire se
déroule essentiellement à Paris Julien
séduit la fille de son employeur
Mathilde non seulement leur passion
devient notoire mais la jeune femme
tombe enceinte le père hésite à accepter
un mariage avec un homme provincial il
refuse finalement après avoir reçu une
lettre de madame de Reynal qui sous
l'influence de son confesseur dénonce
l'ambition et l'immoralité de son ancien
amant Julien se venge alors en tirant
deux coups de feu sur Madame de Rénal
qui survit il est condamné à mort ses
deux anciennes amantes font tout pour le
sauver en vain le rouge et le noir
renouvelle le roman français à plusieurs
titres c'est tout d'abord un modèle de
roman d'apprentissage comme on en trouve
d'autres au XIXe siècle c'est-à-dire que
l'histoire nous fait suivre la
maturation psychologique du héros Julien
Sorel est un provincial ambitieux qui
animait par une énergie napoléonienne
conquiert le savoir les femmes et la
haute société ensuite le rouge et le
noir est un modèle de réalisme Stendhal
s'appuie sur un fait divers et écrit une
histoire crédible Emile Zola le chef de
file du naturalisme la doctrine
esthétique qui proscrit toute
idéalisation de la réalité Zola estimera
en fait que Stendhal est le véritable
père du courant un roman et christindal
dans le rouge et le noir est un miroir
qui se promène sur une grande route
enfin le rouge et le noir est encore un
modèle de roman psychologique parce que
Stendhal analyse en profondeur ce qui se
passe dans l'esprit des personnages tout
particulièrement dans celui du héros il
capture l'essence des émotions humaines
autour au nom du 20e siècle Paul Bourget
et André Gide estimeront même en
exagérant que Stendhal est l'inventeur
de la nouvelle psychologie Nietzsche
quant à lui dira que Stendhal et je cite
le dernier des grands psychologues
français
6e référence Le Père Goriot donnerait de
Balzac
pour vous parler du rouge et le noir de
Stendhal j'ai commencé par vous dire
qu'il était classé troisième du top 10
des plus grands romans de tous les temps
du critique littéraire britannique
William Somerset mogame et bien le Père
Goriot de Balzac est juste derrière
quatrième de ce classement et ce
chef-d'oeuvre a été écrit en seulement
40 jours ah en croire la biographie de
Balzac de Stephen Zweig les cafés bien
fort et la pression des huissiers
permettait aux romancier français de
rester assis 16 heures par jour
personnellement j'ai un petit doute sur
la véracité de cette anecdote mais le
résultat est là le Père Goriot a été
produit très rapidement
que retenir concernant la forme de ce
roman La Prose n'a pas la simplicité de
celle de Stendhal on retrouve les
ingrédients clés du style de Balzac les
phrases longues et les descriptions
abondantes si ces descriptions créent un
univers complet et riche de détails elle
surcharge parfois le texte et peuvent
décourager des lecteurs peu expérimentés
ou peut patients la poésie du style de
Balzac à la même ambivalence d'un côté
il crée de belles images parfois
magnifiques de l'autre côté l'effort
d'éloquence alourdit le style Balzac qui
vendait beaucoup de livres cela pétait
en disant je cite il n'y a à Paris que
trois hommes qui sachent t'écrirent Hugo
Gauthier et moi mais ce n'est pas son
style qu'il a fait passer à la postérité
même les critiques lui reprochent sa
tendance à tartiner qui lui vient
certainement de ses débuts comme Ghost
Writer ainsi que sa tendance à la
généralisation hâtive qui lui vient
certainement de son goût pour la
philosophie
que retenir concernant le fond
maintenant c'est l'histoire d'un père
Goriot d'où le titre du roman qui a
sacrifié toute sa fortune pour ses deux
filles Anastasie et Delphine ces deux
femmes sont mariées à des hommes riches
mais elles ne s'intéressent qu'à leur
propre plaisir réduisant leur père à la
pauvreté Eugène de Rastignac un jeune
homme ambitieux de la province arrive à
Paris pour poursuivre ses études de
droit le nom propre Rastignac deviendra
un nom commun qui désigne une personne
qui veut réussir à tout prix Rastignac
fait la connaissance du Père Goriot et
découvre l'histoire de ses filles il
rencontre votre train un homme
manipulateur qui lui propose de tuer le
mari d'Anastasie pour qu'elle puisse se
remarier avec un homme plus riche eugène
est horrifié et refuse le Père Goriot
meurt abandonné de ses filles et Eugène
est tiraillé entre son amour pour
Delphine et sa conscience morale
bref Balzac dépeint l'ambition et la
corruption de la société française du
début du XIXe siècle à travers le dessin
de Rastignac qui fait son apprentissage
de la vie de la société et des hommes on
retrouve donc la dimension du roman
d'apprentissage Paris en particulier
apparaît comme une ville livrée au
plaisir ou les honnêtes gens se
déchirent entre eux c'est donc le fond
et non pas la forme de ce roman qui en
fait un chef-d'oeuvre il s'inscrit dans
le courant réaliste dans la mesure où il
peint la réalité dans ce qu'elle a de
plus varié mais aussi de plus sordide
Balzac dévoile l'immoralité de la
société parisienne de son époque à
travers des personnages complexes et
crédibles abandonnés par ces filles dans
la vieillesse et la pauvreté le Père
Goriot symbolise la cruauté dans son
capable les individus corrompus par
l'émulation de la vie dans la capitale
Balzac montre plus profondément le rôle
primordial de l'argent dans les rapports
humains dis-moi ce que tu as disait-il
je te dirai ce que tu penses il
enseignes par la fiction la grande leçon
du marxisme puis de l'exist entialisme
la mentalité d'un homme c'est
préférences et ses valeurs découlent de
ces conditions d'existence bref c'est le
milieu qui fait l'homme c'est pour cette
raison qu'on dira que Balzac est un
sociologue ou que certains diront plus
spécifiquement que je cite tout Marx et
d'en Balzac d'ailleurs Marx émet les
romans de Balzac
septième référence le compte de
Monte-Cristo Alexandre Dumas la ville de
Marseille organise chaque année depuis
1999 une traversée à la nage entre le
château d'If et la plage du Rouca blanc
au sud de la ville et il y a jusqu'à
plusieurs milliers de participants même
si une partie se contente d'un parcours
moins long cette traversée commémore
pourtant un événement fictif l'évasion
de prison du héros du roman d'Alexandre
Dumas
dans sa version intégrale ce roman fait
près de 2000 pages le style de Dumas est
vif et fluide ce qui convient bien à une
histoire d'aventure les dialogues sont
vivants la narration est omnisciente ce
qui permet de transporter le lecteur
d'une situation à la suivante et d'un
personnage au suivant et il y en a
beaucoup la prose de Dumas est
globalement plutôt romantique dans la
mesure où il décrit les lieux les
émotions et les sentiments des
personnages mais ce qui est exceptionnel
c'est la maîtrise technique avec
laquelle le romancier réussite à
conserver l'attention du lecteur du
début à la fin la construction de
l'intrigue et des personnages est
redoutablement efficace le compte de
Monte-Cristo est un récit intemporel et
universel qui est encore ce qu'on
appelle un page turner au 21e siècle
quel en est l'histoire le roman raconte
le destin d'Edmond Dantès un jeune marin
de 19 ans cela commence en 1815 au début
du règne de Louis XVII alors que
Napoléon se prépare à quitter l'île
d'Elbe où il était en exil après son
abdication le jeune héros est de mon
dentesse débarque à Marseille pour 6
filles on sait le lendemain avec la
belle catalane Mercedes mais voilà son
bonheur fait déjà loup qui ourdissent un
complot contre lui il est dénoncé comme
conspirateur bonapartiste et enfermé
dans une geôle du château d'If au large
de Marseille il y passera 14 ans il
souffre d'abord de la solitude qui le
plonge dans le désespoir puis il en sort
grâce à son compagnon de captivité
l'abbé Faria cette AB transforme Edmond
Dantès il lui apprend tout ce qu'il sait
son savoir et sa maîtrise des langues il
le soutient dans son projet d'évasion et
avant de mourir il lui signale
l'existence d'un trésor caché dans l'île
de Monte-Cristo c'est comme ça qu'être
bon nantaise devient le compte de
Monte-Cristo
désormais riche Dantès revient dans le
monde sous divers noms d'emprunts
notamment celui du Comte de Monte-Cristo
il entreprend de garantir le bonheur et
la liberté aux rares personnes qui lui
sont restées fidèles en revanche il se
venge méthodiquement de ceux qui sont
responsables de son emprisonnement
pour faire simple le compte de
Monte-Cristo est un des plus grands
roman d'aventure jamais écrit il a
popularisé le genre en France et il a
inspiré de nombreux auteurs cinéastes et
artistes dans le monde entier il a été
adapté une dizaine de fois à l'écran
depuis les années 1950 le héros a
notamment été incarné par Gérard
Depardieu dans un feuilleton réalisé en
ce roman est aussi plus précisément
devenu la référence de la littérature
française sur le thème de la vengeance
comme les grands hommes décrits par
Hegel dans la raison dans l'histoire
Edmond Dantès est habité par une mission
qui lui donne une volonté surhumaine il
est extrêmement pâle il voit dans le
noir et il ne mange pas le pouvoir de
fascination de ce personnage dépasse la
sphère de la littérature le Comte de
Monte-Cristo est devenu une icône
culturelle presque un archétype de
l'imaginaire collectif occidentale il a
inspiré et il inspire encore des
générations de jeunes ambitieux parce
qu'il représente pour eux la vengeance
par le succès sur les personnes qui
n'ont pas cru en eux on reconnaît aussi
dans le dessin d'Edmond Dantès le
parcours mythique du héros il disparaît
du monde pendant un certain temps il
surmonte des obstacles puis il revient
transformés parvenu à la maturité
psychologique petite interruption parce
que je me dis que si vous aimez l'esprit
de cette vidéo à savoir découvrir des
choses intéressantes en allant à
l'essentiel et sans se prendre la tête
alors vous aimerez probablement mon
programme Culture Express c'est un
programme méthodique pour devenir
facilement une personne cultivée en
seulement quelques mois il couvre tous
les domaines de la culture générale vous
maîtriserez les connaissances
essentielles sur l'histoire de
l'humanité sur l'histoire de France en
économie en sciences politiques en
psychologie en sciences en littérature
en art en religion et en philosophie
vous ne serez plus jamais à court de
choses à dire et vous gagnerez la
confiance nécessaire pour briller en
toute circonstance vous pouvez en savoir
plus en cliquant sur le lien qui
s'affiche en haut à droite ou bien sûr
celui qui est dans la description ou
bien encore en tapant directement
l'adresse qui s'affiche à l'écran dans
la barre de recherche et je pense que la
meilleure façon de vous donner une idée
du programme et d'écouter ce que les
membres ont à en dire Valentine et qui
reconnaît l'énorme quantité de travail
que ce programme a représenté pour moi
dit je cite que c'est une véritable mine
d'or l'essentiel est là tout est simple
pratique très bien expliquée concentré
il n'y a plus qu'à recopier et à
apprendre ce travail est vraiment
formidable et passionnant Maxence me
crée directement dans les commentaires
en dessous d'une vidéo du programme la
formation est vraiment remarquable
j'étais un peu dubitatif étant donné le
prix initial mais je ne regrette pas
c'est un vrai travail de synthèse que tu
nous proposes et le format vidéo est
très adapté pour moi qui est une mémoire
essentiellement auditive le choix des
thèmes et des chapitres et pertinents et
je trouve que tu as trouvé la dose
d'approfondissement parfaite à la fois
précis mais sans fioriture vincent lui
fait carrément ma pub j'ai d'ailleurs
recommandé votre formation à ma sœur qui
travaille comme diplomate la semaine
dernière elle a déjà eu l'occasion de
mettre à profit dans ses discussions les
connaissances que vous avez diffusées
vous verrez d'autres témoignages comme
ceci dans les commentaires si vous
rejoignez le programme et si vous vous
inscrivez vous bénéficiez d'une garantie
résultat une fois que vous aurez terminé
le programme je vous rembourserai
intégralement si vous estimez que vous
n'avez pas acquis une solide culture
générale si vous voulez en savoir plus
cliquez sur le lien qui s'affiche en
haut à droite ou bien sur celui qui est
dans la description ou bien encore taper
directement l'adresse qui s'affiche à
l'écran dans la barre de recherche plus
de 800 membres ont déjà tirés parti de
ce programme et je serai ravi qu'il en
soit de même pour vous
huitième référence Madame Bovary de
Gustave Flaubert
ce roman serait le préféré de Brigitte
Macron comme d’emmanuel Macron le
président y a d'ailleurs fait une
référence lors d'une interview à TF1 de
mars 2017 soit un mois avant l'élection
présidentielle alors candidat il
repousse une question de la journaliste
en évoquant un bovarisme journaliste
qu'il définit comme la tendance à se
focaliser sur les étapes suivantes au
lieu de parler des affaires du moment
cette expression inspirée par le roman
de Flaubert fait référence à la
propension de l'héroïne à s'échapper de
la réalité présente en se projetant dans
ses fantasmes
que dire de la forme de ce roman on
retrouve le souci de la perfection de
Flaubert qui polie chaque phrase dans le
détail par un travail acharné de
retouche il a travaillé à ce roman
pendant 5 ans en testant l'acadence et
l'harmonie du texte au gueuloir on le
surnomme monsieur un mot par jour parce
qu'il écrit très lentement son
vocabulaire riche et précis plutôt que
vague et abstraite sont vocabulaire
riche et précis décrit les personnages
et les scènes de manière détaillée
Flaubert opte souvent pour des
structures de phrases longues et
complexes avec l'ambition de créer un
rythme unique grâce à l'usage du
discours indirect libre il s'efface
derrière son œuvre qui doit donner
l'illusion d'exister par elle-même il
utilise de manière magistrale le style
indirect libre il n'introduit pas les
paroles et les pensées du personnage
avec un verbe si bien que les voix du
personnage est celle du narrateur sans
chevêtre enfin il est habilement
ironique la sophistication de la pose de
Madame Bovary peut rebuter un lecteur du
21e siècle mais elle fait de Flaubert un
des plus grands stylistes de la
littérature française
je vous résume rapidement le roman
Flaubert s'est inspiré sur le conseil de
deux de ses amis d'un fait divers récent
le suicide de l'épouse d'un officier il
anti-HA l'histoire démarre Rouault une
jeune femme qui rêve de la vie
passionnante et romantique qui a
découvertes dans ses lectures de
jeunesse elle épouse Charles Bovary un
médecin de province et malheureusement
elle se sent rapidement déçue par leur
vie monotone et sans relief elle m'a
fait la connaissance de diverses
personnalités locales dont le pharmacien
monsieur oh mais le curé bournisien
Leclerc de notaire Léon Dupuis et le
libertin Rodolphe boulanger elle sombre
dans la dépression et entame des
liaisons avec le libertin et le notaire
mais ces relations se révèlent
décevantes Emma s'est étendettée pour
ses achats compulsifs de vêtements et
d'objets luxueux et pour financer ses
relations extra-conjugales et un jour le
marchand qui lui a prêté de l'argent
exige d'être remboursé incapable de
payer ses dettes et désespérées emma se
suicide son mari meurt de chagrin Berthe
leur fille et confiée à une tente et
envoyé travailler dans une filature de
coton
Madame Bovary fait de Flaubert le plus
grand auteur du dernier tiers du XIXe
siècle parce qu'il lance la nouvelle
orientation littéraire à laquelle vont
se rallier ses contemporains pour faire
simple son roman symbolise le passage du
romantisme au réalisme Flaubert avait
auparavant écrit un roman dans le style
lyrique propre au romantisme mais ses
amis lui avaient conseillé de le jeter
au feu parce que le romantisme était
passé de mode les lecteurs voulaient
désormais qu'on les intéresse à la
réalité contemporaine Flaubert a suivi
leur conseil à contrecoeur parce qu'il
vomit la bourgeoisie il met donc en
évidence dans Madame Bovary la vulgarité
de la bourgeoisie de province la
bassesse de son pragmatisme cela fait de
son roman une des plus célèbres
critiques du mode de vie bourgeois dans
la littérature mondiale
mais l'idée plus profonde qui ressort du
dessin d'Emma Bovary ce sont les ravages
du bovarisme évoqué par Emmanuel Macron
c'est-à-dire le désir que l'existence
quotidienne ressemble à ce qu'on lit
dans les romans Flaubert prend ainsi
position sur la trivielle et très
importante question de l'influence de la
fiction sur la réalité si son héroïne
est malheureuse c'est parce que les
romans qu'elle a lu dans sa jeunesse ont
fait naître chez elle des attentes
irréalistes
[Musique]
neuvième référence Les Misérables de
Victor Hugo en 2019 sort un film
intitulé Les Misérables le réalisateur
français ladge lit transpose les thèmes
du roman de Victor Hugo la pauvreté
l'injustice et la violence policière
dans la banlieue parisienne du début du
21e siècle le long-métrage qui dépasse
le million d'entrée en salle montre que
le chef-d'oeuvre publié il y a plus de
150 ans et toujours une référence
pertinente pour parler des inégalités
sociales les misérables est un des
romans les plus populaires de la
littérature française malgré ses 2600
pages Hugo qualifié son livre de
montagne mais il existe aujourd'hui des
versions abrégées de quelques centaines
de pages
sur la forme la prose de Hugo qui est le
chef de fil du romantisme est très
poétique pleine de métaphores elle est
parfois crue lorsqu’il s’agit de faire
sentir la difficulté des conditions de
vie des personnages Hugo donne une voix
unique à chaque personnage grâce à des
accents des dialectes et des tiques de
langage ce qui donne beaucoup de
réalisme à l'histoire enfin les
descriptions détaillées ne sont pas
rares ce qui va bien sûr rebuter un
lecteur du 21e siècle la description des
égouts de Paris est si précise et
détaillée que le lecteur peut presque
sentir l'odeur putride et entendre le
bruit de l'eau
l'action se déroule en France au début
du XIXe siècle Victor Hugo raconte
pendant 5 tomes le destin de Jean
Valjean un força échappé du bagne frappé
par la générosité de l'évêque Myriel à
son égard il essaie désormais de faire
le bien autour de lui il promet à
Fantine une pauvre femme mourante de
prendre soin de causette sa fille
exploitée par un couple d'aubergistes
les thénardiers seulement sont passés et
l'inspecteur Javert le rattrape Jean
Valjean ne sauve donc la petite causette
qu'après cette évadé de prison il se
dissimule avec elle dans un couvent
quelques années plus tard le jeune
Marius tomba amoureux de causette lors
de l'insurrection républicaine du 5 juin
1832 Jean Valjean sauve à la fois
l'inspecteur javère ainsi que Marius
qu'il ramène sans connaissance à travers
les égouts de Paris en revanche le petit
Gavroche personnage qui symbolise les
enfants des rues parisiennes meurent
héroïquement sur les barricades
Marius épouse Cosette puis il veut
l’éloigner de Jean Valjean après avoir
découvert son passé alors Jean Valjean
se meurt dans la solitude et le chagrin
mais lorsque Marius apprend tardivement
que le forçat qu'il veut fuir lui a
sauvé la vie il se rend auprès de lui
avec causette ayant revu la petite fille
qu'il avait prise sous sa protection
j'envahl Jean peu je cite mourir comme
un saint
Les Misérables marquent la littérature
française parce que c'est un récit aux
qualités exceptionnelles en effet il
émet le réalisme dans la description de
la pauvreté du début du XIXe siècle
l'épopée dans le récit de grandes
aventures notamment le destin de Jean
Valjean et il mêle également l'amour
romantique mais aussi familiale le but
essentiel des Misérables est de dénoncer
la misère c'est un roman social et donc
aussi politique car Hugo il décrit les
conditions et les conflits des
différentes classes sociales il s'est
beaucoup documenté pour cela il écrit
dans la préface je cite tant qu'il y
aura sur la terre ignorance et misères
délivre de la nature de celui-ci
pourront ne pas être inutiles
Hugo dénonce plus précisément
l'exploitation de l'homme par l'homme
l'indifférence à la misère et la
répressivité du système il considère que
la peine de mort est une hérésie à ses
yeux la solution réside dans
l'instruction des masses dès l'enfance
enfin l'influence des Misérables dépasse
le champ de la littérature ces
personnages sont si célèbres et qu'ils
sont devenus des noms communs dans le
langage courant on parle par exemple
d'une causette pour désigner une jeune
fille surexploitée par ses employeurs ou
ses parents on parle aussi d'un
Thénardier pour désigner un exploiteur
et dans un sens plus général un
l'histoire des Misérables fascine même à
l'étranger le livre est très populaire
en Asie où il a même été adapté en manga
dixième référence 20 milieux sous les
mers de Jules Verne
ce roman était le livre préféré du
célèbre explorateur polaire Ernest
chatelton lorsqu'il était enfant il y a
puisé son inspiration alors quand son
équipage est lui son piéger dans les
glaces de l'Antarctique en 1914 il fait
passer des exemplaires à ces hommes la
légende dit que 20 milieux sous les mers
leur a donné la force mentale pour
sortir de leur situation désespérée
sur le plan de la forme le style de
Jules Verne à plusieurs qualités la
narration à la première personne permet
au lecteur de voir le monde à travers
les yeux du protagoniste le professeur
Aronax les avantages de cette solution
ce sont une meilleure immersion dans
l'histoire et une identification plus
forte avec les personnages bref on a
l'impression d'y être une autre qualité
du style de Verne c'est le métissage de
la poésie et de la science d'un côté il
dépeint avec poésie les paysages
sous-marins et les créatures qui vivent
ces descriptions détaillées immergent le
lecteur dans le monde merveilleux et
dangereux des profondeurs de l'océan il
réussit à créer une atmosphère
mystérieuse et fascinante et de l'autre
côté Verne évoque parfois la vie
sous-marine avec des termes
scientifiques il parle également des
machines et des inventions de l'époque
comme le scaphandre autonome et le
sous-marin lui-même avec un langage
précis et technique
après la pause de Jules Verne ne plaît
pas à tout le monde le lecteur du 21e
siècle peut être ennuyé par la lenteur
de la narration il peut trouver que les
descriptions nuisent à la fluidité du
récit qu'il y en a trop par rapport à
l'action mais bon la langue de Vern est
quand même claire et simple facile à
lire et à comprendre ce n'est pas pour
rien que ces romans ont été si
populaires auprès d'un large public
maintenant je vous résume rapidement
l'histoire en 1866 la presse relate
l'apparition d'une créature marine
monstrueuse qui causerait des naufrages
elle sème la terreur dans les océans du
monde entier et concrètement c'est un
problème pour les compagnies d'assurance
maritimes pierre Aronax un professeur de
biologie marine est invité à participer
à une expédition Visante à traquer la
bête Aronax embarque sur l'Abraham
Lincoln avec son fidèle de mystique
conseil et le harponer un nedland qui
est originaire de Québec au cours de
l'expédition ils sont attaqués par la
créature et écho sur son dos il s'agit
en fait d'un sous-marin futuriste le
Nautilus Aronax conseil et nedland ils
sont fait prisonniers par le mystérieux
capitaine Nemo un homme qui a fui la
surface et la société il découvre
l'intérêt scientifique de Némo pour les
fonds marins mais ils comprennent
également qu'il utilise le Nautilus
comme une arme de guerre il attaque des
navires afin de se venger de l'humanité
les trois prisonniers cherchent un moyen
de s'échapper d'une Nautilus tout en
explorant les merveilles du monde
sous-marin il découvre des créatures
étranges et merveilleuses des trésors
engloutis l'Atlantide et des épaves
d'anciens navires ils s'aventurent sur
les îles du Pacifique et la banquise du
Pôle Sud il chasse dans les forêts
sous-marines et combattent des calmar
géants finalement Aronax Ned est
conseillent réussissent à s'échapper du
Nautilus mais on ne sait pas ce qu'il
adviendra de Nemo et de son sous-marin
20 000 lieux sous les mers et
certainement le meilleur roman de Jules
Verne son importance dans l'histoire de
la littérature tient essentiellement à
l'impulsion qu'il donne au genre de la
science-fiction qu'on peut définir par
le fait que l’auteur imagine une société
future née de certains progrès
techniques dans ce roman Jules Verne
vulgarise les sciences et les
technologies de son époque il met
notamment en évidence l'importance de
l'électricité et puis il anticipe aussi
le progrès technique il imagine des
appareils futuristes comme les
prochaines générations de sous-marins ce
roman a révolutionné la littérature
populaire en introduisant des thèmes
scientifiques et techniques dans la
fiction il a ouvert la voie à une
nouvelle génération de romans d'aventure
c'est pour ça que Jules Verne est
considéré comme un des deux pères
fondateurs avec le Britannique Herbert
George Wells du roman de science-fiction
20 milieux sous les mers à plus
généralement eu une influence importante
dans la culture populaire occidentale il
passe d'ailleurs pour un des livres lits
plus traduit au monde je dis passe parce
qu'il n'existe pas de statistiques
fiables son influence culturelle tient à
deux choses tout d'abord il a promu la
science et la technologie dans
l'imaginaire collectif et puis le
capitaine Nemo un des personnages les
plus célèbres de Jules Verne est un peu
devenu un archétype il incarne l'homme
solitaire qui s'oppose à la société il
est aussi un héros écologique car Verne
lui fait dénoncer la dégradation de
l'environnement en particulier la
dégradation de la mer dont il dit
qu'elle est je cite le vaste réservoir
de la nature
[Musique]
onzième référence germinal d'Émile Zola
nous sommes en 1912 lors du procès pour
diffamation d'Anatole France un des
écrivains les plus populaires de
l'époque le juge lui demande si la lu
Germinal de Zola avec lequel il s'est
réconcilié à l'occasion de l'affaire
Dreyfus bien sûr qu'il l'a lu le juge
lui demande alors s'il ne pense pas que
ce roman a incité à la révolte non
monsieur le juge répond à Anatole France
germinal n'a pas incité à la révolte il
a empêché la révolte en effet ce roman a
eu une grande influence politique en
donnant à voir les conditions de travail
épouvantables des mineurs il a montré
qu'une réforme sociale était nécessaire
dans ce roman La Prose à deux
caractéristiques principales le réalisme
et le naturalisme le style est réaliste
parce que Zola décrit crûment les
conditions de travail et de vie des
mineurs leurs vêtements par exemple une
scène m'avait marqué de mémoire une
adolescente prolétaire qui se donne
rapidement à un homme dans un coin dans
un buisson ou derrière un arbre l'idée
que cela véhicule c'est que les ouvriers
s'accouplent comme des animaux bien
évidemment une telle scène choque le
bourgeois de l’époque le réalisme de
Zola se retrouve encore jusque dans le
choix des mots il n'hésite pas à se
servir de termes vulgaires pour faire
sentir la violence du quotidien des
mineurs comme je vous l'ai dit son style
est également naturaliste le naturalisme
c'est la doctrin esthétique et qui
proscrit toute idéalisation de la
réalité il faut au contraire faire
ressortir la nature au sens des faits
typiques de l'expérience humaine et
c'est fait typique doivent montrer que
l'homme obéit aux lois de la nature
celle de son corps notamment et qu'il
est le produit de son milieu par exemple
qu'une AD ça coupe rapidement derrière
un buisson comme une bête cela
s'explique à la fois par son instinct de
reproduction et par le dénuement dans
lequel vivent les prolétaires qui
résultent
ultimement de force économiques et
sociales la comparaison des mineurs à
des animaux qui expriment le point de
vue des bourgeois cette comparaison est
récurrente dans le roman cela recourt
plus généralement à des métaphores pour
évoquer la souffrance des mineurs il
compare par exemple la mine à un monstre
à l'appétit immense qui avale les hommes
et les digèrent lentement son style peut
sembler lourd à un lecteur du 21e siècle
mais il est quand même bien clair
comparé à d'autres auteurs de l'époque
Zola est même un des auteurs que je
recommande aux personnes qui souhaitent
lire pour améliorer leur expression
écrite parce que sa langue est à la fois
claire classique et accessible
je passe au résumé de l'histoire le
jeune Étienne Lantier et le fils de
Gervaise Macquart le personnage
principal d'un autre best-seller
naturaliste de Zola l'Assommoir qui
dépeint les ravages de la misère et de
l'alcoolisme chez les ouvriers Zola
avait relié entre beaucoup de
personnages de son grand cycle
romanesque les Rougon-Macquart nous
savons donc déjà que le jeune Étienne
Lantier a eu une enfance compliquée
entre le départ de son père les
difficultés financières de sa mère et
l'alcoolisme de son beau-père au début
de Germinal il cherche un nouvel emploi
il s'est fait virer du précédent dans
les chemins de fer du Nord de la France
parce qu'il a donné une gifle à son
employeur il se fait embaucher dans les
mines de montsoul où les conditions de
travail sont horribles il habite chez
une famille de mineurs les maeux ils
tombent amoureux de leur fille aînée
Catherine mais celle-ci se refuse à
quitter l'ouvrier brutal quelle
fréquente
le penchant pour la révolte d'Étienne se
réveille lorsque l'entreprise qui
l'emploie veut leur imposer une baisse
de salaire il pousse les mineurs à la
grève et leur transmet son désir de
justice sociale mais la confrontation
avec l'entreprise est très dure les
dirigeants refusent de la négociation et
les ouvriers résistent pendant plusieurs
semaines le mouvement continue même
après que les soldats ont rétabli
l'ordre les ouvriers en viennent à
défier les soldats ceci tirent alors sur
les manifestants tuant notamment MAE qui
héberge Etienne certains d'entre eux
ayant perdu la vie dans le mouvement les
mineurs se résignent à reprendre le
travail alors survient un événement qui
fait prendre un tournant au destin
d'Étienne un anarchiste sabote le puits
condamnant de nombreux mineurs à mourir
dans l'effondrement et l'inondation des
galeries bloquée avec Catherine la femme
dont il est amoureux et chavale l'amant
violent de Catherine Etienne est le seul
à sortir vivant
il repart à Paris pour défendre la cause
ouvrière si les mineurs de montsoul sont
retournés au travail ils sont désormais
animés d'une conscience politique pour
faire simple germinal et le roman de la
lutte des classes celui qui symbolise
l'arrivée du marxisme en France Zola
dénonce les conditions de travail
épouvantables des mineurs dans le nord
de la France et ils montrent que cette
misère ne peut qu'acoucher de la révolte
c'est d'ailleurs le sens du titre du
roman germinal et l'adjectif
correspondant au nom commun germination
qui désigne le développement d'une
nouvelle plante à partir d'une semence
l'idée du titre c'est donc que le sort
épouvantable des prolétaires et la
semence de la révolution à venir on
retrouve également cette idée dans le
fait que germinal est un mois du
calendrier révolutionnaire français
correspondant au début du printemps et
donc à la renaissance de la nature et
par là le titre du roman est aussi une
référence à la Révolution française la
plus célèbre des révoltes
ce roman est également important dans
l'histoire de la littérature pour une
seconde raison il est emblématique du
courant naturaliste les conditions de
vie des ouvriers sont un bon sujet pour
la conception de l’écriture de Zola le
romancier naturaliste doit écrire sous
la dictée de la réalité pour faire
oeuvre de science il décrit l’humanité
ordinaire en s'effaçant derrière
l'histoire il ne peut pas se permettre
de commenter ou d'interpréter l'effet
comme le faisait Balzac si on suit cela
un roman n'est presque plus une oeuvre
de fiction
mais la portée de Germinal dépasse la
littérature et la France les nombreuses
traductions lui ont permis d'être lu
dans le monde entier c'est un classique
de la littérature mondiale et puis c'est
aussi une œuvre politique ce que
signifie la réponse d'Anatole France au
juge qui lui demande si germinal n'a pas
incité à la révolte c'est que ce roman a
au contraire fait prendre conscience aux
élites françaises de la nécessité
d'améliorer le sort des ouvriers soit
par humanité soit pour éviter la
révolution
12e référence Bel-Ami de Guy de
Maupassant
début 2009 paraît Bellamy mais
be2le et a mis avec un e une biographie
à charge contre Rachida Dati la ministre
de la Justice de Nicolas Sarkozy alors
que cette ministre est à l'époque
unicône de la méritocratie et un symbole
de la diversité le livre dénonce la
rivisme de son parcours qui devrait tout
à l'intrigue et à la séduction en le
comparant au destin de Georges du Roy le
personnage du roman de Maupassant on
retrouve dans le style de Maupassant la
simplicité et le réalisme du courant
naturaliste parce qu'il a brièvement
évolué dans l'orbite de Zola il dépeint
la haute société parisienne de la fin du
19e siècle dans un langage direct sans
fioriture il décrit les intérieurs des
appartements les vêtements les gestes et
les comportements avec une grande
précision ce qui permet au lecteur de
s'immerger dans le microcosme de l'élite
parisienne
une autre caractéristique du style de
Maupassant dans Bel-Ami c'est qu'il est
efficace pour conserver l'attention du
lecteur par exemple il met en place des
retournements de situation pour
maintenir la tension narrative sur le
plan du choix des mots enfin Maupassant
c comme tout écrivain talentueux
produire des images évocatrices par
exemple il compare à plusieurs reprises
Georges du roi à un prédateur sauvage
soit un animal insaisissable et
opportuniste
je passe à l'histoire du roman Georges
du roi vient de passer plusieurs années
en Algérie en tant que militaire comme
beaucoup d'ambitieux il monte à Paris
pour faire fortune et comme beaucoup
d'ambitieux la dure réalité de la jungle
parisienne déçoit ses attentes il doit
se contenter d'un poste minable à la
Compagnie des chemins de fer du Nord
mais le destin le favorise lorsqu'il
tombe sur un ami perdu de vue comme
Charles forestier et rédacteur en chef à
la vie française il y embauche George
comme journaliste mais voilà Georges n'a
pas le niveau pour écrire il a besoin de
l'aide de la belle et riche femme de son
ami Madeleine forestier dont il tombe
amoureux pour réussir à boucler les
articles en plus de lui donner un
travail son ami le présente à la Société
parisienne
Georges du roi montre rapidement les
échelons grâce à ses talons de
séducteurs et à son réseau il nous des
amitiés intéressés et il fait bien sûr
des jaloux il accède à la reconnaissance
sociale en épousant à la fille d'un
riche homme d'affaires ce qui ne
l'empêche pas de poursuivre une relation
amoureuse avec une ancienne maîtresse de
son ami à un moment c'est multiples
intrigues amoureuses lamenta devoir
choisir entre vivre des sentiments
authentiques et la réussite sociale
Georges Duroy s'est bien imposé dans les
élites parisiennes mais il réalise qu'il
a corrompu son âme pour parvenir à ses
fins
pour faire simple Bel-Ami et le roman de
référence de la littérature française
sur le thème de la rivisme Maupassant
dépeint l'immoralité de la vie sociale
parisienne de l'époque où le succès ne
dépend pas des compétences ni de la
morale il analyse la psychologie de
l'ambition à travers les conflits
intérieurs de Georges du Roy qui se rend
compte de la corruption de saâme son
évolution est symbolisée par les scènes
où il se regarde dans le miroir au début
de son ascension il se découvre en homme
du monde à travers les miroirs quand ils
gravit les escaliers pour se rendre chez
forestier
Bel-Ami est également important dans
l'histoire de la littérature française
parce qu'il est emblématique du courant
réaliste Maupassant évoque le contexte
social et politique de son époque il
fait par exemple des références à
l'expansion coloniale de la France il
décrit les mœurs de son époque il
dépeint des microcosmes qu'ils connaît
comme celui des journaux de son époque
il écrira que le romancier réaliste doit
je cite donner la vision plus complète
plus saisissante plus probante que la
réalité même
le succès littéraire de Bel-Ami a
rapporté beaucoup d'argent à Maupassant
son histoire se distingue des autres
histoires d'ambitieux celle de Balzac
par exemple par le fait qu'elle
représente l'arrivisme à l'état pur
Georges du Roy n'a aucune compétence à
offrir il est simplement séduisant elle
symbolise par là le penchant à
l'immoralité des élites elle sera
adaptée de nombreuses fois à la
télévision et au cinéma
[Musique]
13ème référence l'immorialiste
d'andrégide en 1922 le régime fasciste
de Mussolini interdit ce roman il estime
que sa représentation de l'homosexualité
et sa critique de la morale
traditionnelle sont trop subversifs pour
la société italienne les milieux
littéraires protestent en vain la
psychologie humaine étant ce qu'elle est
l'interdiction renforce la renommée
internationale du livre en Italie même
des exemplaires clandestins continuent
de circuler sous le nez des autorités
fascistes
la controverse n'est pas étonnante car
le titre annonce la couleur un
immoraliste c'est quelqu'un qui
professeait l'immorialisme c'est-à-dire
une doctrine qui se définit simplement
par son opposition à la morale établie
c'est-à-dire par la controverse bref le
titre du roman portant lui-même l’idée
de la controverse
les moraliste brise également les
conventions sur la forme le style
d'andrégide est avant-gardiste
c'est-à-dire qu'il est précurseur dans
la rénovation de la prose on peut le
qualifier d'expérimental il recouvre au
symbolisme pour évoquer des images
complexes et paradoxal je rappelle qu'un
symbole c'est un signe qui renvoie à une
autre chose à laquelle il est lié par un
rapport de ressemblance par exemple j de
décrite un espace naturel de manière à
suggérer la coexistence de la beauté et
de la décadence oui c'est compliqué
autre innovation les événements sont
filtrés à travers la subjectivité du
narrateur enfin la langue de Gide son
vocabulaire en particulier sa langue est
d'une grande richesse poétique comme le
reconnaîtront de grands écrivains et la
beauté du style est d'autant plus
frappante qu'elle contraste avec la
sombreur des thèmes
que retenir du fond du roman c'est
l'histoire de Michel un érudit passionné
par l'histoire ancienne mais qui vit de
manière très conventionnelle fraîchement
mariée à Marceline il part avec elle en
voyage de noces en Afrique du Nord il
tombe malade si malade qu'il craint d'y
passer mais plutôt que la mort il vit sa
convalescence comme une nouvelle
naissance une fois rétablie il change de
perspective sur la vie notamment sur le
plan moral d'où le titre du roman alors
qu'il était un érudit peu porté sur la
chair le désir renaît en lui on retrouve
là l'idée de la volonté de puissance de
Nietzsche dont j'était fan on comprend
également l'homosexualité latente du
personnage attirée par la spectaculaire
santé des jeunes garçons arabes qui
l'accompagnent au cours de promenade
de retour en Normandie où il doit
reprendre son mode de vie conventionnel
il se rend compte qu'il est attiré par
ce qu'il y a sous le vernis de la
civilisation il fréquente des hommes qui
ne vivent pas selon les conventions
lui-même il n’est plus l'homme civilisé
qu'il était après la fausse couche de sa
femme il fuit son existence bourgeoise à
travers l'Afrique puis l'Europe où sa
femme trouvera la mort
marque la littérature française à la
fois sur le fond et sur la forme il
explore des thèmes controversés tout
particulièrement l'homosexualité il est
un des premiers à aborder ouvertement la
question ce qui lui vaudra d'être
interdit dans plusieurs pays et si j'ai
des réussites à évoquer des sujets
controversés de manière subtile c'est
grâce à l'originalité de son style
expérimental il ne faut cependant pas
réduire cette innovation au symbolisme
parce que j'ai de lui-même était gêné
par l'excessive abstraction du
symbolisme ce roman est encore
emblématique à un autre égard les
gothisme des écrivains du tournant du
XXe siècle c'est-à-dire leur propension
à s'étudier eux-mêmes et à parler de
même c'est l'époque de l'émergence de la
psychanalyse l'oeuvre comme l'analyste
est censé délivrer l'auteur de ses
névroses elle devient le lieu où il
dénonce tout ce qui fait ou a fait
obstacle à son épanouissement personnel
les problèmes non résolus dans l'enfance
les blocages à l'origine des conflits
psychiques les conflits familiaux Gide
inspirera beaucoup d'auteurs à dénoncer
l'entrave de la société au libre
déploiement du mois il passera aussi
pour un précurseur du surréalisme dans
la mesure où son style refléterait
l'activité spontanée de l'esprit dans la
liberté des associations d'idées
notamment
en résumé l'IM moraliste est un roman
incontournable parce qu'il promeut de
nouveautés et une nouvelle manière
subjective symbolique et subtile d'en
parler André Gide est avec Marcel Proust
le plus grand romancier français du 20e
siècle
14e référence à la recherche du temps
perdu de Marcel Proust
Marcel Proust écrit dès l'adolescence et
n’embrasse aucune carrière après ses
études ce qui signifie surtout vous
l'avez compris qu'il n'a pas besoin de
travailler depuis sa jeunesse il
fréquente des salons aristocratiques où
il rencontre artiste et écrivains ce qui
lui vaut une réputation de dilettante
mondain c'est à cause de cette
réputation que Gallimard refuse le
premier tome du roman qui sera le plus
grand de la littérature française au 20e
siècle grâce à elle accepte de publier
le premier tome mais à conte d'auteurs
c'est à dire que Proust paye tous les
frais de sa poche mais ça tombe bien il
a les moyens Gaston Gallimard le
fondateur de la maison d'édition se rend
ensuite compte qu'il a loupé un bon coup
c'est donc lui qui publie le deuxième
tome il y aura en tout sept tomes du
côté de chez Swann à l'ombre des jeunes
filles en fleurs le côté de Guermantes
Sodome et gomores la prisonnière
Albertine disparue le temps retrouvé
les deux derniers tomes ont été publiés
après la mort de Proust grâce aux soins
de son frère mais Proust lui-même les
aurait certainement repris j'ai lu les 7
hommes de la recherche au début de la
vingtaine au cours d'un été où j'ai
passé beaucoup de temps à lire au soleil
au jardin du Luxembourg pour être
honnête avec vous j'ai souffert pour
aller au bout et j'ai très moyennement
aimé d'un côté proust'écrit très bien
c'est vrai il analyse finement les
individus et les situations et il dit
beaucoup de choses pénétrantes sur la
nature humaine mais de l'autre côté
comme j'aime l'idéal de concision du
français classique j'ai trouvé les
phrases les paragraphes les plus
généralement les tomes beaucoup trop
longs et c'est d'autant plus long que
l'histoire est ennuyeuse et que les
personnages ne sont pas inspirants après
le livre date d'une époque où la
concurrence n'était pas si féroce parmi
les producteurs de divertissement c'est
à dire que les lecteurs arrivaient à se
plonger dans un livre si long pour la
simple et bonne raison qu'il n'avait pas
beaucoup d'autres options pour se
divertir
que retenir du fond maintenant
honnêtement c'est pas passionnant
l'histoire de la recherche mêle la
biographie du narrateur à la mise en
scène de la société mondaine des
dernières années du 19e siècle le
narrateur est comme Proust un jeune
bourgeois hypersensible dont l'ambition
est d'être écrivain seulement il perd
son temps en mondanité parmi
l'aristocratie ou dans les lieux de vie
législature à la mode il découvre en
grandissant la dynamique des relations
sociales et en particulier celle de
l'amour coupé du monde par la maladie et
la guerre il prend conscience de la
vanité de sa vie mondaine et se convainc
de son aptitude à enfin devenir écrivain
l’épisode le plus célèbre de la série de
roman est celui dit de la madeleine de
Proust dans Du côté de chez Swann le
narrateur décrit comment la réminiscence
d'un rituel de son enfance a été
déclenché en trempant le petit gâteau
dans du thé je cite et tout d'un coup le
souvenir m'est apparu ce goût c'était
celui du petit morceau de madeleine que
le dimanche matin à Cambrai ma tante
Léonie m'offrait après l'avoir trempé
dans son infusion de thé ou de tilleul
madeleine de Proust est devenu une
expression courante elle désigne un
petit événement qui fait resurgir 2 RE
souvenir d'enfance
de manière plus générale le roman est
une réflexion psychologique sur la
littérature la mémoire et le temps
l'histoire montre qu'on connaît les
autres à travers la sélection arbitraire
par notre esprit de certains traits
ainsi dans la passion amoureuse on
n'aime pas l'être réel mais une
construction de notre esprit mais on
peut retrouver la vérité par
l'introspection le titre à la recherche
du temps perdu résume l'idée majeure à
savoir qu'on peut découvrir le sens
profond de son existence en explorant
ses souvenirs
dans l'histoire de la littérature la
recherche marque un tournant sur le plan
des thèmes elle symbolise l'égotisme des
romanciers c'est-à-dire leur propension
à s'étudier eux-mêmes et à parler
d'eux-mêmes à la publication du premier
tome en 1913 Marcel Proust passe pour un
novateur les premières critiques le
comparent à Montaigne le destin de la
littérature du 20e siècle est tout
entier contenu dans une phrase du
dernier tome intitulé Le temps retrouvé
je cite je compris que tous ces
matériaux de l'oeuvre littéraire c'était
ma vie passée le sens de cette
révolution littéraire c'est qu'écrire
devient un synonyme de mettre en scène
son individualité le critique littéraire
Fernand van Derem dit peu après la
Première Guerre mondiale que les romans
sont devenus je cite des hautes à
souvenirs et à impression personnelle
plus le siècle avance plus cela sera
vrai la mise en abyme dans l'ouvrage de
l'auteur en train de composer son livre
cette configuration devient de plus en
plus fréquente puis se banalise les deux
grands auteurs du XXe siècle Marcel
Proust et André Gide recourent tous les
deux à cette configuration
après le premier quart du XXe siècle les
romanciers modernes répètent
inlassablement le modèle de la recherche
ainsi Marcel Proust est devenu un des
noms les plus prestigieux de la
littérature tout court en parlant de sa
vie personnelle et en disséquence les
états d'âme sur des milliers de pages
désormais l'écrivain ne prétend pas
accéder à l'universel être la voie de la
vérité il respecte scrupuleusement la
sensation comme Proust il préfère
décrire les choses telles que les
perçoit la conscience du narrateur vous
aimez les gros manuels c'est bien c'est
pas une partie de plaisir mais comment
faire si vous voulez découvrir les idées
d'Aristote par exemple et bien aller sur
le site 1000 idées de culture générale
vous tapez Aristote dans la barre de
recherche et vous avez les synthèses des
synthèses très claires des meilleures
idées d'Aristote rédiger avec amour et
beaucoup de café par votre serviteur et
comme le nom l'indique 1000 idées de
culture générale ce n'est pas que de la
philo vous trouverez aussi les
meilleures idées en économie en
littérature en histoire en sciences
politiques en psychologie etc alors
maintenant que faire de ces gros manuels
alors moi je les garde parce qu'ils sont
bien pratiques pour pour remplir la
bibliothèque quand je tourne des vidéos
mais vous vous pouvez vous en servir
comme support pour poser la casserole ou
bien pour faire de la musculation si
vous n'aimez pas les haltères classiques
c'est moins fatiguant que de les lire
vous n'avez pas besoin de vous prendre
la tête pour découvrir le meilleur de la
pensée allez simplement sur 1000 idées
de culture générale
[Musique]
référence Voyage au bout de la nuit de
Louis-Ferdinand Céline
la publication de voyage au bout de la
nuit en 1932 ébranle la militaire air
française le mélange de violence est
d'originalité de ce roman le premier
d'un auteur écrivant ce pseudonyme ne
laisse personne indifférent les
critiques sont abasourdi les écrivains
se partagent en deux quand les partisans
admiratifs et les adversaires
scandalisés le livre sort tellement du
lot par rapport à ce public lié à la
même période que le prestigieux pris
Goncourt en lui semble promis un membre
du jury raconte que la décision avait
été prise mais que les jurés sont
revenus de super peur du scandale
Voyage au bout de la nuit représente une
révolution sur le plan de la forme le
style de Céline y est unique par son
anticonformisme des tests entières ont
été écrites sur l'innovation que
représente cette prose mais sa dimension
essentielle et que Céline ne respectent
pas la différence entre l'écrit et
l'oral
la conception de l'écriture héritée de
l'époque classique présuppose que la
Parole écrite est plus noble que la
parole et par conséquent qu’on en noblit
son expression en parlant comme on écrit
avec ordre et clarté Céline lui fait
l'inverse il puise dans la langue parlée
pour renouveler la langue écrite l'effet
est double on y gagne sur le plan
politique avec des images originales et
du rythme mais en même temps la
vulgarité entre guillemets de l'oral
pénètre la langue écrite en pratique
cela donne de l'argot des jurons qui
choquent les critiques de l'époque ou
encore un usage qui peut paraître
excessif des petits points Céline crée
également des néologisme comme
voyoucratie ou sacril léger enfin la
langue parlée est d'autant plus
frappante dans Voyage au bout de la nuit
que Céline est également capable
d'écrire avec un français classique
l'alternant entre les deux registres de
langue crée un puissant effet de
contraste
que retenir de l'histoire de ce roman
maintenant en fait c'est
l'autobiographie romancée de Céline donc
un mélange de vrais et de faux on suit
les aventures de Ferdinand bardamus
l'alter ego de l'auteur le roman
commence par son enfance dans les
faubourgs de Paris puis suit ses voyages
en Afrique et en Amérique et sa
participation à la Première Guerre
mondiale tout au long de ses voyages
bardamus rencontre des personnages
marginaux des prostituées des
colonisateurs brutaux et des
intellectuels égocentriques la structure
de la narration n'est pas linéaire c'est
une succession de situations avec des
flashbacks des ellipses et des sauts
dans le temps qui illustre l'incapacité
du héros à donner un sens global à son
existence
les thèmes du roman sont
particulièrement sombres l’absurdité de
la guerre la misère la corruption ou
encore l'exploitation coloniale bardamus
et confrontée à la mort à la maladie et
à la folie cherchant désespérément un
sens à sa vie il retourne finalement à
Paris où il se résigne à sa condition et
plus généralement à celle de l'humanité
cette conclusion explique le titre La
vie est un voyage au bout de la nuit au
sens où elle se résume à explorer la
médiocrité et la misère de la condition
humaine historiquement l'expression
Voyage au bout de la nuit est tiré d'un
couplet chanté par un soldat de Napoléon
au cours de la bataille de la Bérézina
je cite notre vie est un voyage dans
l'hiver et dans la nuit nous cherchons
notre passage dans le ciel ou rien ne
lui
en quoi ce roman est-il incontournable
dans l'histoire de la littérature
française sur le fond il passe pour un
chef-d'oeuvre nihiliste le destin de
bardamus illustre une conviction qui se
diffuse à l'époque la vie n'a pas de
sens en soi le pessimisme qui émane de
la pose de Céline témoigne d'une
lucidité sans concession en particulier
Voyage au bout de la nuit est aussi une
référence sur le thème de la
condamnation de la guerre comme d'autres
grands écrivains de l'époque je pense
notamment à stevenswig Céline défend
l'idée que la guerre c'est simplement en
dernière instance les élites qui
envoient le peuple à l'abattoir
sur la forme comme je l'ai dit ce roman
renouvelle le style littéraire il montre
que la langue parlée est une riche
source de créativité pour importer de
nouvelles images et de nouveaux rythmes
dans la langue écrite le style de Céline
fascinera et influencera beaucoup
d'auteurs ultérieures il les désignera
il leur donnera le courage d'être
originaux même si bien sûr beaucoup se
contenteront d'écrire à la manière de
Céline il inspirera certains à libérer
bien plus radicalement la langue écrite
à partir de la langue parlée à l'image
de Jacques Kerouac le célèbre auteur de
sur la route le roman qui a annonce la
révolution culturelle des années 1960
en revanche le message de voyage au bout
de la nuit a été un peu oublié par la
postérité c'est certainement parce que
les pamphlets antisémites écrits par
Céline dans les années 1930 lui ont fait
perdre tout crédit intellectuel certains
lui refusent carrément sa place dans la
littérature française à cause de ses
livres mais tout de même en 1999 une
consultation populaire française classe
Voyage au bout de la nuit à la sixième
place des 100 meilleurs livres du 20e
siècle
[Musique]
16e référence la nausée de Sartre
lorsque ce roman sort en 1938 il produit
dans le monde littéraire un effet
comparable à celui du Voyage au bout de
la nuit de Céline on parle de Sartre
pour le prix Goncourt ce succès est la
récompense d'un long effort cela fait 8
ans que Sartre a commencé à écrire ce
roman Les Éditions Gallimard ont même
pris 12 mois pour réviser le manuscrit
sur les conseils d'un avocat elles ont
fait pression sur Sartre pour qu'il
supprime les passages trop crus ce qui
représentait pas mal de pages mais
Sartre peut dire merci à son éditeur
parce que c'est Gaston Gallimard
lui-même qui trouve le titre la nausée
le mot nausée vient du grec nozia mal de
mer qui désigne une envie de vomir et
par extension un dégoût violent que
retenir de la forme le roman est écrit à
la première personne Antoine roquentin
raconte son histoire de manière
introspective en évoquant ses crises
métaphysiques étant donné que Sartre et
philosophe de formation sont styles est
plutôt sec presque professoral parmi
ceux qui n'aiment pas la nausée certains
disent que c'est une dissertation
déguisée en roman après Sartre crée
quand même des images pour décrire
l'état émotionnel du protagoniste il
fait aussi ressentir le malaise du
personnage en répétant le mot nausées
enfin il est bien romancier quand il
décrit les lieux et les personnages dans
le détail son style est globalement
accessible Sartre combine des phrases
courtes et des phrases longues ce qui
crée du dynamisme sur le plan du
vocabulaire il sait faire simple et
juste s'approse se complexifie en partie
la structure de la phrase lorsqu'il
décrit les pensées du protagoniste cela
correspond certes à l'esprit torturé
d'Antoine roquentin mais c'est un style
lourd pour le lecteur
que retenir du fond maintenant Antoine
roquentin qui est un peu l’alter ego de
Sartre est un historien d'une trentaine
d'années il vit seul à Bouville une
ville imaginaire qui rappelle Le Havre
ou Sartre a été prof de philo de 26 ans
à 31 ans attiré par l'aventure et
l'exotisme il avait voyagé puis il avait
travaillé en Indochine mais là c'est il
vit désormais de ses rentes ce qui lui
permet de travailler à la biographie
d'un aristocrate de la fin du XVIIIe
siècle
le texte du roman est celui du journal
intime d'Antoine roquentin dans lequel
il décrit son évolution psychologique il
sent la nausée monter en lui les objets
quotidiens créant lui une impression
désagréable puis cette impression
s’étend à tout repentant se rend compte
du vide de sa propre existence et du
dégoût qu'il en ressent ce vide
existentiel le détache de tout y compris
des relations humaines sa rencontre et
ses échanges avec un autodidacte à la
bibliothèque ne dissipe pas à sa nausée
comme ça ne supporte pas la bourgeoisie
provinciale il se désintéresse du
personnage de l'aristocrate sur lequel
il veut écrire donc il abandonne son
projet de livre alors il se replie sur
lui-même il prend conscience par une
introspection philosophique du vertige
radical de son existence il revoit son
ex-compagne Annie et apprend qu'elle va
partir pour Londres le laissant lui dans
une solitude absolue sans aucune attache
avec l'humanité mais peut-être sortira
t-il de la nausée et se
réconciliera-t-il avec la vie en
écrivant un roman
la nausée et la référence du courant
existentialiste en littérature comme la
conférence L'existentialisme est un
humanisme l'est en philosophie pour
rappel l'existentialisme et le courant
philosophique du 20e siècle qui affirme
la vocation de l'homme à définir
lui-même par ses actes ce qu'il entend
être c'est dans ce sens que Sartre dira
que je cite l'existence précède
l'essence
à travers le personnage d'Antoine
roquentin la nausée met en scène et
analyse le malaise existentiel qui
accompagne la prise de conscience
individuelle du fait que le monde et
l'existence sont dépourvus de sens que
l'homme est condamné à être radicalement
libre ce que Sartre appelle la
contingence soit l'absence de
déterminisme c'est de cette prise de
conscience que découlent la morale
existentialiste selon laquelle l'homme
doit se réaliser dans l'action notamment
dans l'engagement pour la libération
sociale
ce roman sera un pilier de
l'existentialisme qui deviendra un
mouvement culturel majeur au cours des
trentes glorieuses il est aussi un
exemple célèbre de l'effet psychologique
de la lecture l'atmosphère d'un roman
peut contaminer l'état émotionnel du
lecteur comme beaucoup de gens je me
suis senti mal à l'aise en lisant la
nausée certains vont jusqu'à
déconseiller ce roman aux personnes
dépressives et je suis un peu d'accord
[Musique]
17e référence l'étranger d'Albert Camus
devenu première dame de France en
épousant le président Nicolas Sarkozy en
2008 la mannequin est chanteuse Carla
Bruni a donc été amenée à rencontrer les
dirigeants de la planète lors de voyage
diplomatiques elle a par exemple raconté
son échange avec George Bush junior le
président américain de l'époque ils ont
parlé d'Albert Camus et bouche lui a
révélé que l'étranger était son livre
préféré il s'agit d'un petit roman moins
de 200 pages qui se lit facilement on
retrouve la simplicité et la concision
qui sont la marque de fabrique du style
d'Albert Camus qui est un des meilleurs
exemples du fait qu'il n'est pas
nécessaire d'écrire des phrases
compliquées pour être un grand écrivain
Camus se sert de phrase courte et
directes pour décrire les événements et
les pensées du personnage principal il
évite les longues descriptions et les
analyses psychologiques complexes ils
préfèrent laisser les événements et les
actions parler d'eux-mêmes le célèbre
incipit les deux premières phrases du
roman en est un exemple l'éloquent je
cite aujourd'hui maman est morte ou
peut-être hier je ne sais pas c'est très
et pourtant ça on dit long sur la
psychologie du personnage dont on
comprend immédiatement qu'elle n'est pas
celle de l'homme ordinaire Camus adapte
également son style au contenu du roman
il émane un grand détachement de ses
choix de mots qui reflètent l'attitude
distante et stoïque du protagoniste
maintenant je vous résume l'intrigue le
personnage narrateur Meursault vit à
Alger à l'époque de l'Algérie française
apprenant la mort de sa mère il se
déplace pour la veillée et les
funérailles il semble étonnamment peu
affecter par la disparition en fait il
n'est pas triste et il n'est pas prêt à
faire semblant des événements décisifs
surviennent dans les jours suivant
l'enterrement Meursault retrouve une
femme qui avait travaillé dans la même
entreprise que lui Marie et ils entame
une relation son voisin Raymond un
proxénète notoire l'implique dans ses
problèmes de couple il maltraite sa
maîtresse et craint les représailles de
ses frères Meursault témoignera en sa
faveur lorsque la police convoquera
Raymond au commissariat dans les jours
suivants Meursault accepte la demande en
mariage de Marie en précisant que cela
n'a pas d'importance à ses yeux
c'est alors que ce produit l'événement
déterminant dans son destin lors d'une
promenade Raymond un ami et Meursault
tout droit sous l'effet conjoint peut
favorable à la lucidité de l'alcool et
de la chaleur il croise le frère de la
maîtresse battue par Raymond et une
bagarre éclate par précaution Meursault
avait demandé à Raymond de lui confier
son revolver pour éviter un drame mais
lorsque seul cette fois-ci Meursault
rencontre à nouveau un des hommes qui
s'est battu avec Raymond plutôt et que
cet homme sort un couteau alors
Meursault sort le revolver et tu d'une
seule balle l'homme qui le menace puis
de manière inexplicable il tire quatre
autres coups sur le corps inerte
commence alors la seconde partie du
roman dans laquelle le processus
judiciaire met en lumière l'étrangeté de
Meursault son absence de regret et son
ennui de l'existence mettent son avocat
mal à l'aise son attitude et son état
émotionnel ne change pas lors du procès
son explication maladroite il explique
son acte par une hallucination causée
par le soleil le fait passer pour un
sociopathe il est condamné à mort dans
ces derniers instants il refuse le
secours de la religion préférant se
préparer seul à la mort
Albert Camus refusait à l'étiquette
existentialiste mais il passe dans la
littérature française pour l'autre grand
romancier existentialiste après Sartre
Meursault et roquentin le protagoniste
de la nausée de Sartre partage
l'indifférence au désir et aux normes de
la société mais leur psychologie n'est
pas exactement la même le personnage de
Camus vit dans l'absurde et
l'incompréhension celui de Sartre dans
le dégoût sur le plan de la forme
l'étranger marque la littérature
française par la puissance de la
simplicité du style de Camus cette
simplicité contraste avec les analyses
psychologiques complexes qui étaient
courantes à l'époque comme avec les
longues descriptions qui alourdissent
les romans des siècles précédents le
style de Camus est emblématique de la
simplification de la prose anticipée par
Jack London notamment au tournant du
20ème siècle c'est aussi un retour aux
valeurs du style classique la clarté et
la concision
sur le plan plus général de la culture
l'influence de l'étranger est à replacer
dans le grand mouvement
d'affaiblissement de la tradition au 20e
siècle comme la nausée il a joué un rôle
dans l'élargissement des horizons
littéraires et philosophiques de
l'époque
[Musique]
18e référence Le Petit Prince d'Antoine
de Saint-Exupéry
traduit dans plus de 300 langues ce
livre serait le plus lu au monde après
la Bible une des raisons c'est qu'il
n'est pas difficile à lire il ne fait
qu'une centaine de pages et Antoine de
Saint-Exupéry écrit avec une langue
simple et accessible le petit prince
passe avant tout pour un contour enfant
le style est très poétique mais sans
être compliqué la plupart des phrases
sont courtes ce qui permet de
transmettre des idées claires tout en
faisant avancer l'histoire à un rythme
soutenu les phrases tendent néanmoins à
s'allonger lorsque Saint-Exupéry explore
des thèmes plus profonds 80 ans après la
parution du livre la simplicité poétique
de son style plait toujours autant au
lecteur adulte comme enfant ils sont
toujours impressionnés par la capacité
de Saint-Exupéry à évoquer des idées
philosophiques de manière à métaphorique
je vous résume rapidement l'histoire le
narrateur est un aviateur en panne de
moteur dans le désert du Sahara il y
rencontre le personnage du Petit Prince
qui lui demande de dessiner un mouton
ils apprennent à se connaître le petit
prince raconte qu'il vient d'une planète
à peine plus grande qu'une maison et
qu'il a laissé derrière lui trois
volcans et une rose unique dont il est
amoureux il a aussi visité d'autres
planètes avant d'arriver sur terre il y
a rencontré des individus bizarres qui
sont des archétypes comme un roi qui
prétend tout gouverner un vaniteux qui
se prend pour l'homme le plus beau et le
plus intelligent alors qu'il est seul
sur sa minuscule planète un homme
d'affaires qui passe son temps à compter
les étoiles dont il est propriétaire ou
encore un ivrogne sur terre le Petit
Prince a notamment rencontré un renard
qui lui a délivré une leçon importante
sur la valeur de l'amitié l'aviateur en
apprend davantage sur son petit ami
chaque jour jusqu'à leur séparation le
8ème jour le petit prince retourne sur
sa planète le narrateur quant à lui peut
quitter le désert après avoir réparé son
avion il part en espérant revoir le
petit prince un jour
l'importance du Petit Prince dans la
littérature se résume au fait qu'il est
probablement la plus puissante allégorie
sur la laideur du monde des hommes au
départ considéré comme un conte pour
enfant il est devenu un conte
philosophique pour les adultes la figure
du Petit Prince sert à mettre en
accusation le monde des adultes où il
n'est plus possible de goûter la beauté
de la vie avec la pureté de l'enfance
si ce roman a si bien marché c'est parce
qu'il permet à tout un chacun de méditer
des thèmes universels la solitude
l’amitié l'amour le sens de la vie à
partir d'images aussi puissante que
simple lire Le Petit Prince est une
expérience à la fois émotionnelle et
philosophique spirituelle voire
initiatique le lecteur ressort
transformé la figure du Petit Prince
c'est imprimée dans l'imaginaire
collectif surtout occidental Elie
symbolise le point de vue de l'innocence
de la pureté dans un monde compliqué et
sombre ou la pureté est introuvable
surtout à l'époque de la deuxième guerre
mondiale au cours de laquelle écrit
Saint-Exupéry ces aquarelles d'une
simplicité enfantine ont également
contribué à populariser le personnage du
Petit Prince l'histoire a été diffusée
au-delà de la littérature grâce à de
nombreuses adaptations
cinématographiques musicales et
théâtrales
Saint-Exupéry et son petit prince sont
devenus une référence incontournable de
la culture française au point qu'ils
illustrent le billet de 50 francs en
19e référence la Gloire de mon père de
Marcel Pagnol
au cours d'une discussion avec la femme
d'un ami qui travaille pour le magazine
de mode l Marcel Pagnol promet d'écrire
sur son enfance mais comme il se
consacre au cinéma et au théâtre ce
projet littéraire n'est pas sa priorité
seulement ça promet ce n'est pas tombée
dans l'oreille d'une sourde la femme de
son ami lui rappelle le son engagement
et c'est grâce à cette pression sociale
qu'un des romans les plus emblématiques
de la culture française un roman
autobiographique voit le jour que dire
de la Gloire de mon père sur la forme
Pagnol raconte l'histoire de son enfance
à la première personne ce qui donne un
côté intime à la narration autrement dit
le lecteur se relit plus facilement au
personnage principal dont il partage les
expériences et les émotions le style de
Pagnol facilite également l'immersion
dans l'histoire il décrite efficacement
les personnages les situations et les
paysages les expressions et les mots
provençaux donnent de l'authenticité et
de la couleur au récit l'humour des
dialogues rend la lecture agréable
le style de Pagnol est globalement
simple et vivant ces phrases directes
plutôt courtes ou moyenne conserve
l'attention du lecteur le long de
l'histoire son langage accessible crée
une atmosphère conviviale et chaleureuse
le talent littéraire de Pagnol réside
dans sa capacité de rendre l'histoire
savoureuse et dans la peinture des
caractères c'est-à-dire à la psychologie
des personnages
que retenir de l'histoire maintenant
Marcel PAGNOL a raconte sa naissance et
ses origines familiales il raconte
également les promenades au parc avec sa
tante Rose lorsqu'il a 6 ans qui sont un
prétexte pour passer du temps avec
l'homme dont elle était prise qui
deviendra longue Jules
une dimension importante des souvenirs
de Pagnol et la naissance de son
attachement pour la Provence qui
survient lorsque sa famille et celle de
sa tante partage une maison de campagne
pour les vacances d'été de 1904 le jeune
Marcel et son frère tombe amoureux de
l'environnement emblématique de la
Provence les collines les rushes et la
végétation un événement donne son titre
roman Marcel suite en secret son père et
son oncle parti à la chasse il les perd
puis il les retrouve grâce au son des
coups de fusil il était moins d'un petit
exploit de son père il a réussi à
abattre une paire de perdrix en plein
vol en un seul tir ce qui fait la gloire
de son père dans le village mais dans un
accès de vanité son père accepte de se
faire prendre en photo avec les oiseaux
alors que lui-même s'était moqué d'un
collègue qui avait fait la même chose
avec un poisson cette faiblesse est
dissout l'image idéale que Marcel a de
son père mais renforce son amour filial
la Gloire de mon père a marqué la
littérature française pour deux raisons
tout d'abord il est devenu l’œuvre
emblématique des souvenirs d'enfance
l'école primaire le cocon familial les
vacances dans les collines provençales
ou encore la chasse avec le père ne sont
certes pas le lot de tous les enfants
mais ces ingrédients symbolisent dans
l'imaginaire collectif une enfance
épanouie c'était épanouissement tient en
bonne partie aux personnages humains
mais aimant et attachant que décrit
Pagnol avec le succès fulgurant du livre
le père instituteur à la mère timide
l'oncle l'attente et le petit frère sont
devenus des figures très populaires
la seconde raison pour laquelle la
Gloire de mon père a marqué la
littérature française et la mise en
valeur de la Provence la région de
Marseille le roman donne une image
idyllique de la région la nature est
magnifique les villages charmants les
habitants chaleureux et leur coutumes
agréables
la portée culturelle de ce livre dépasse
la seule littérature il a nourri deux
archétypes celui de l'enfant s'épanouit
dans une famille harmonieuse en
particulier dans la relation au père a
opposé à l'idée freudienne prégnante à
l'époque de l'enfance et du complexe de
DIP comme source de névrose et puis
l'archétype de la Provence comme région
idyllique l'adaptation au cinéma a
renforcé ses archétypes notamment celui
de la Provence dont les images
permettent d'admirer les paysages
20e référence la promesse de l'aube de
Romain Gary
c'est le rapport de Romain Gary à la
vérité qui autorise à classer ce livre
parmi les romans le récit est certes
très autobiographique mais l'auteur
multiplie les entorses avérés à la
réalité factuelle il aime mystifier les
lecteurs la presse et l'opinion publique
il écrit certains romans sous son vrai
nom d'autres sous le pseudonyme d'Emile
Ajar et il fait tenir le rôle public de
cet écrivain à son petit cousin la
tromperie réussie si bien que Gary
décroche deux fois le prix Goncourt ce
que les règles du concours interdisent
sur la forme le livre est accessible le
style exprime une grande sensibilité de
manière relativement simple Gary décrit
les relations humaines tout
particulièrement celles qui l'entretient
avec sa mère avec des images fines et
puissantes son art de la métaphore
transparaît lorsqu'il donne vie à ses
souvenirs enfin il manie l'autodérision
ce qui le rapproche du lecteur au total
la prose de Gary est fluide avec des
phrases de longueur variables qui
s'adapte au rythme du récit il rend la
narration captivante en variant les
procédés stylistiques métaphores
comparaison saisissante jeux de mots
dialogues enlevés
voici maintenant un résumé de l'histoire
Romain Gary est à la fois l'auteur et le
narrateur sa mère a beaucoup d'ambition
pour lui elle prédit qu'il deviendra
célèbre elle reporte ses espoirs sur lui
après avoir renoncé à sa carrière
d'actrice elle lui donne énormément
d'amour mais elle est envahissante
lorsqu'ils vivent dans la Lituanie
actuelle au début du roman romain et
sait la peinture la musique et la danse
mais il se tournent finalement vers
l’écriture comme Hitler arrive au
pouvoir ils vont s'installer à Nice
parce que la mère de Romain adore la
France les débuts de leur vie d'immigrés
sont difficiles jusqu'à ce qu'elles
deviennent gérantes d'un hôtel il se
sépare lorsque romain part faire une
licence de droit à Paris mais la mère
continue de suivre le destin de son fils
et de l'alimenter de sa foi lui de son
côté ne veut pas la décevoir lorsqu'une
promotion militaire lui est refusée
parce qu'il n'est pas français depuis
assez longtemps il ment à sa mère en lui
disant qu'il paie en réalité ces phrases
que de séducteur il aurait couché avec
la femme du chef ensuite elle lui écrit
de nombreuses lettres lorsqu'il combat
lors de la deuxième guerre mondiale
résistant il est promu capitaine à la
fin du conflit seulement il ne peut pas
goûter la fierté de sa mère il apprend à
son retour en France qu'elle est morte
depuis plusieurs années il devient
écrivain comme sa mère l'avait prédit
mais elle n’est plus là pour le voir
réaliser l'ambition qu'elle avait placé
en lui
pour faire simple ce roman est dans la
littérature française la référence sur
le thème de l'amour maternel est plus
précisément de la relation mère-fils
l'hommage que Romain Gary rend à sa mère
est une réflexion profonde sur le
rapport à l'existence qu'engendre
l'amour inconditionnel d'une mère c'est
le sens du titre qui est tiré d'une
phrase du livre je cite avec l'amour
maternel la vie vous fait à l'aube une
promesse qu'elle ne tient jamais mais la
promesse est double d'un côté la vie
fait office une promesse d'amour
inconditionnel mais cet amour
disparaîtra avec la mère et le fils
devra poursuivre son existence seule
rendu dépressif par l'attente irréaliste
d'un amour comparable à celui de la
source maternelle l'autre côté de la
promesse de l'aube c'est le fils qui
promet à sa mère d'accomplir ses vœux de
succès
si ma mère avait tué un amant je
n'aurais pas passé ma vie à mourir de
soif auprès de chaque fontaine écrit
joliment Romain Gary
le style est très bon et Romain Gary
contribue à renouveler le récit
autobiographique par son subtil mélange
de la réalité et de la fiction mais
c'est le sujet du roman qui a touché le
cœur de tant de lecteur c'est une
démonstration magnifique du fait que
l'amour maternel peut être à la fois une
bénédiction et une malédiction
si vous aimez l'esprit de cette vidéo à
savoir à découvrir des choses
intéressantes en allant à l'essentiel et
sans se prendre la tête alors vous
aimerez probablement mon programme
Culture Express c'est un programme
méthodique pour devenir facilement une
personne cultivée en seulement quelques
mois il couvre tous les domaines de la
culture générale vous maîtriserez les
connaissances essentielles sur
l'histoire de l'humanité sur l'histoire
de France en économie en sciences
politiques en psychologie en sciences en
littérature en art en religion et en
philosophie vous ne serez plus jamais à
court de choses à dire et vous gagnerez
la confiance nécessaire pour briller en
toute circonstances vous pouvez en
savoir plus en cliquant sur le lien qui
s'affiche en haut à droite ou bien sûr
celui qui est dans la description ou
bien encore en tapant directement
l'adresse qui s'affiche à l'écran dans
la barre de recherche et je pense que la
meilleure façon de vous donner une idée
du programme et d'écouter ce que les
membres ont à en dire Valentine et qui
reconnaît l'énorme quantité de travail
que ce programme a représenté pour moi
dit je cite que c'est une véritable mine
d'or l'essentiel est là tout est simple
pratique très bien expliqué concentré il
plus qu'à recopier et à apprendre ce
travail est vraiment formidable et
passionnant Maxence mécré directement
dans les commentaires en dessous d'une
vidéo du programme la formation est
vraiment remarquable j'étais un peu
dubitatif étant donné le prix initial
mais je ne regrette pas c'est un vrai
travail de synthèse que tu nous proposes
et le format vidéo est très adapté pour
moi qui est une mémoire essentiellement
auditive le choix des thèmes et des
chapitres et pertinents et je trouve que
tu as trouvé la dose d'approfondissement
parfaite à la fois précis mais sans
fioriture vincent lui fait carrément ma
pub j'ai d'ailleurs recommandé votre
formation à ma sœur qui travaille comme
diplomate la semaine dernière elle a
déjà eu l'occasion de mettre à profit
dans ses discussions les connaissances
que vous avez diffusées vous verrez
d'autres témoignages comme ceci dans les
commentaires si vous rejoignez le
programme et si vous vous inscrivez vous
bénéficiez d'une garantie résultat une
fois que vous aurez terminé le programme
je vous rembourserai intégralement si
vous estimez que vous n'avez pas acquis
une solide culture générale si vous
voulez en savoir plus cliquez sur le
lien qui s'affiche en haut à droite ou
bien sur celui qui est dans la
description ou bien encore taper
directement l'adresse qui s'affiche à
l'écran dans la barre de recherche plus
de 800 membres ont déjà tirés parti de
ce programme et je serai ravi qu'il en
soit de même pour vous dans tous les cas
j'espère que la vidéo vous a plu je suis
romain et vous vous étiez sur 1000 idées
de culture générale rappelez-vous vous
n'avez pas besoin de vous prendre la
tête pour vous intéresser au meilleur de
la pensée
[Musique]